what do you think about when you hear
award visionary ride the word visionary
when i telled award visionary to mario
my buddy here who works here on a daily
basis he thinks about Walter Mercado
because he likes to watch Walter Mercado
from is it Univision yeah on the other
hand my buddy or Paul Paul is a fan of
Miss Cleo he's a big fan of Miss Cleo
tear it card statue miss visionary right
and then we have visionaries a more
morale in Tigran these guys sit on have
a Norman Armenian coffee together and
they put their thumb in there with our
mini coffee Tony and run for like five
minutes and then they say someone is
gonna come visit you from a very far
distance today and they're bringing
money with them right this whole
visionary I'm not talking about that
kind of visionary
oh when I'm talking about visionary I'm
talking about real time visionary
because if you think about great
countries great civilizations great
churches great businesses great families
great anything is it becomes dead
because there was a visionary that
casted a vision for that business that
family that that country whoever it is
and people bought into it and there was
a lot of pressure on a visionary to make
that vision become a reality but a
visionary is only an event away from
being a phony and a phony is only an
event away from being a visionary let me
explain what I mean by that so who is a
visionary when you think about a
visionary you know initially a vision
had a visionary has a vision that they
see that the future you know
such-and-such is gonna happen okay
whatever it may be here's what could
happen in many times visionaries are
probably some of the most misunderstood
people in the world because when a
visionary gets up and says we are one
day going to go to America the land of
the free this is a family they're living
in Iran they're living in China their
own Russia
they're immigrants they're in South
America and they wanna want to come to
America everybody in their family says
you know like a brother or say you're
crazy no one's ever going to America
we're never going to get you no
citizenship to go from here you are you
out of your mind and families will say
things somebody will say we are one day
going to build a multi-billion dollar
opportunity that's gonna do XYZ a lot of
people who say what an arrogant
conceited person to say that it'll ever
happen we are one day going to build the
greatest nation in the world what an
arrogant group of people that live in
this lala land you escaped Britain to
come over here and you think you're
gonna build a craters country of altima
there's been civilizations that have
been around for thousands of you're
gonna come out and do something big you
are arrogant for saying that
so visionaries are misunderstood there's
violently opposed people call them phony
they call them crazy they live in this
fantasy world they're living in dreams
right there they because they say it so
because they say it they're a phony they
people say they're BS sir he's a liar
total liar every you know look what he
says they're gonna do this that's never
gonna happen he's a liar don't believe
him you guys are never gonna go to
America and be free he's a liar he's
just trying to sell you a lie and at the
end of the day one of those two groups
is going to be right because if a
visionary doesn't fulfill any promise of
his vision then you have a phony you
know you ever met people that talk a
very big game oh I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do we're gonna do this we're gonna
do this we're gonna do that and they
always say it eventually nobody believes
any word that's coming out of their
mouth that's a phony and then you have
the visionary now there are different
levels of visionary let's talk about the
three different levels of what a
visionary is you know that the highest
level of visionary is somebody that's a
world changer you know that's the one
that we read about in the books like you
know MLK Martin Luther King is a
visionary where the world knows about
and he did something that's just out of
this world it wasn't something small it
affected everybody right Graham Bell who
said you know people are gonna talk
amongst each other through a phone a
machine a mechanism no wires no nothing
gonna be able to talk to each other now
Graham Bell created this right when you
think about Edison how a light is turned
on that's a visionary I'm gonna light up
the world and people not don't need a
candle anymore and he pretty completely
he's a world-changing visionary the
second level of visionary is a you know
celebrity visionary you can you can call
this kind of visionary a famous
visionary so it could be an ally who
would say I'm gonna knock out
such-and-such a seventh round
that's a visionary he said he's gonna do
it and it happened right Billy Beane who
is from the movie Moneyball that said
the best way to put a team together is
you don't need to go get the homerun
hitters it's about on-base percentage
because if you go on on base percentage
on how often this guy makes it on base
those are the teams that are gonna make
it so the philosophy of Oakland and then
went to Boston Red Sox and that's a
visionary that's a person who's a vet
George Lucas made of movie star wars
that they said this is never gonna
happen he's out of his mind what are you
talking about to make a movie like this
you're you're full of it you're arrogant
you're you're insane he's lost it he's a
little bit of a maniac he's he's nuts
he's crazy
that's a visionary but that's a famous
visionary right that's not a
world-changing missionary but that's
still a visionary but the kind of
visionary that doesn't get a lot of
credit is sometimes the everyday
visionary and let me explain to what I
mean by the everyday visionary listen a
family who sits down and a father says
boys you know this is a special family
and one day all three of you are gonna
get a college degree and you guys going
to have your own good families are you
gonna raise that could be a visionary
that's a pressure on the father because
the father has to work to provide to put
the kids through school and there's a
pressure on the kids to deliver on the
vision and kids don't believe it that
you're crazy no one in our family has
ever had a degree we grew up in Compton
we grew up in you know Chicago the bad
side of Chicago we grew up in you know
Brooklyn we grew up in bad parts of you
know LA we grew up no one's gonna get a
degree no one in our family has ever
gotten a degree you live what are you
talking about that
that's a visionary but that's an
everyday visionary that we don't see
that that person doesn't necessarily get
a recognition that's on a history books
but that person is gonna get recognition
and that family lineage that'll be
remembered that's still a visionary when
when a family a father or mother says
we're gonna kiss we're gonna go to
America one day and the kids have some
level of Hope in them to believe hey
you're watching a movie Rocky one day
we're gonna take you to America hey
husband says to his wife honey you told
me you're Italian but you've never been
to Italy before him on a one day take
you to Italy that's a visionary
that's a visionary said honey I'm gonna
take you to Italy that's a that's an
everyday visionary and when he takes his
wife to Italy he went from a phony to a
visionary because the dream became a
reality and that's a visionary that's a
certain level of visionary that we're
talking about now again I said it
earlier the difference between visionary
and a phony is one event a phony keeps
saying what he's gonna do and doesn't
happen a visionary doesn't it does
happen so how does one go about you know
becoming a visionary when you think
about what I want to be known as a
visionary myself great you know there's
a lot of pressures of being a visionary
this is why a lot of people don't want
to be a visionary for for instance
what's the pressure of being a visionary
there's a very high likelihood of you
being wrong there's a very very high
likelihood of you being wrong when you
claim to be a visionary you know there's
a very high likelihood of it you know
you could put that pressure on yourself
this is why when somebody claims that
something's gonna happen they don't get
a lot of sleep at them because all
they're thinking about is I got to make
sure this thing becomes a reality so the
pressures of being a visionary whether
it's on the everyday level or the famous
level or the world-changing level it
doesn't matter it's a lot of pressure of
being a visionary because the first step
of a visionary is what they envision
something they have a moment where they
see they say I think this is gonna
happen and then you must share that
vision and declare that vision and
intention with other people at the
everyday level could be to your family
honey our family is one day going to
come together we're all going to be
under one roof one day celebrating
someone's birthday
take 10 20 years but this is gonna
happen we will have a family reunion
even though we're all scattered all over
the world honey that's going to happen
and then that person has the pressure of
spending the next 5 10 15 20 years of
making sure that event takes place
because it's important to them to become
a visionary it is important to them to
become a visionary right so how do you
constantly improve and become a
visionary
you got a declare an intention and keep
it and the more intentions you declare
and the more of your intentions you keep
the more stronger you're becoming of a
visionary the more you say it and
nothing happens the less everybody
believes in your word and the less you
believe in your word you are losing your
credibility of a visionary right so it
starts off with a small vision and it
becomes a reality honey I think in the
next 90 days I'm gonna take you to a
nice three-day weekend we're gonna go to
such and such place hold that commitment
your wife may think it's not real and
then it happens boys girls if we do this
we're gonna go to Disneyland before the
end of the year kids see it all that's
it we're gonna go to this event boom it
becomes a reality kids if you do good in
your grades I see ourselves going to
Hawaii next you boom it happens you go
to I so now the family slowly but surely
start to trust into what you're worth
and you on a certain smaller level or
becoming the visionary of your family
you could say it in your business and
say listen we're gonna grow and we're
gonna be in five states within the next
24 months and you go and become and turn
into six states people are now starting
to trust your word you say hey we're
gonna go out there and bring on board
the best talent and we're gonna do X Y Z
the trust that you have people that have
trust in your ward goes higher so then a
visionary starts having a reputation the
moment you have the reputation of what
you say becomes a reality now you've got
to go and cast more difficult visions
now you've got to go out there and put
your name on the line for more
challenging things to do in life rather
than the everyday ones cuz you've
already done that and your family
already believes your word on what's
going to be taking place on the
realities that's going to take place
when you cast any
kind of a vision and he declare your
intention so the higher and higher and
no more commitments you make next thing
you know you're going from you know
being the everyday visionary and your
family to the next thing you know you're
doing stuff that the world knows about
you know you're doing stuff that people
are reading about but I believe in my
opinion I believe everybody can
strengthen their muscle of being a
visionary and that's including you and
it starts off with you declaring an
intention to your family declaring an
intention to the people you work with
declaring an intention to those you're
in business with and going out there and
taking that pressure that you have while
everybody calls you crazy everybody
calls you a liar of phony all these
rumors that are going to be created
about you whether this person has no
clue what they're talking about you know
lalala and all that stuff and then when
the vision becomes a reality when the
vision becomes a reality the faith in
your word goes to a whole different
level not from you to you but from a lot
of other people to you where the next
time they're just hoping you don't
declare any more intentions because if
you declare more intentions they know
something crazy may happen because you
fight so hard to keep your intentions
because it's important to you to keep
the reputation of a visionary so we
started off with my buddy here Walter
Mercado and and miss miss miss miss Cleo
and we ended up coming back to you on
what would happen if you want it to be a
visionary if you want to go through it
again you can watch through it again if
you want to share with another person
please feel free to do so as well
you got any questions and comments post
it on the bottom and if you haven't
subscribed to our channel please be sure
to subscribe to the channel as well
thanks for watching
you